en un ambiente de profunda devoción
50.000 fieles se congregaron en el
Vaticano para asistir al funeral del
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 este jueves la
misa presidida por el Papa Francisco
duró un poco más de una hora durante su
homilía Francisco rindió homenaje a su
predecesor habló de su sabiduría de su
delicadeza al final de la misa el
féretro fue trasladado a la cripta de la
Basílica de San Pedro para su entierro
en el interior del ataúd junto al cuerpo
de ratzinger se introdujeron las
medallas y monedas acuñadas durante su
pontificado también el llamado rollito
un breve texto con los actos más
destacados del Papa emérito finalmente
se procedió a la inhumación en la tumba
en la cual reposó Juan Pablo II antes de
ser canonizado ser enterrado allí fue
una de las últimas voluntades de
Benedicto 16 el primer papa que renunció
a su cargo en seis siglos de historia